2020 ist wirklich wild entschlossen ein
echtes misst ja zu bleiben oder gibts
doch gar nicht ständig corona rekorde
neuerdings ein infizierter
gesundheitsminister und die konsumlaune
im land bricht auch schon wieder einmal
ganz abgesehen vom ekligen l wort das
über allem schwebt kommt der große
lockdown doch noch zurück wirklich das
zieht ein alles nur noch runter gibt es
denn gar keine guten nachrichten mehr
doch beruhigen will auch die
bundesregierung in dem sie einer wohl
noch nie da gewesene garantie ausspricht
eine klopapier garantie versprochen vom
verkehrsminister klopapier werde es
immer genug geben und wann hätte uns an
die scheuer jemals angelogen ja zur not
kann er sogar eine eigene klopapier
marke rausbringen hergestellt aus
original maut verträgen als idee wie
ernst die lage ist erkennt man
spätestens daran dass angela merkel in
ihrem wöchentlichen podcast zum ersten
mal regelrecht emotionen gezeigt hat wo
kriegt die bevölkerung direkt angst die
kanzlerin bittet uns um hilfe weil sie
sich bei den länderfürsten nicht mehr
durchsetzen kann ist nicht besonders
vertrauenserweckend uns bürgern brennen
existenzielle fragen auf den nägeln
kommt bald die echte rezession reichen
die intensivbetten und natürlich eine
andere frage kommt von dem zuschauer
henry kowalewski er fragt habe ich als
arbeitnehmer einen anspruch auf
büromöbel im home-office die zu meiner
wohnung passen oder kann der arbeitgeber
verlangen dass ich zum beispiel mal ein
bürostuhl mit nach hause nehmen muss das
sind probleme ja muss mir der
arbeitgeber wegen corona ein neues haus
bauen wenn ich mein altes dorf findet wo
wir ihn gerade bei wünsch dir was sind
wäre es eventuell möglich dass markus
söder mal nur einen tag lang eine
pressekonferenz gibt dinge das ist mir
wirklich mein persönlicher traum
es bringt doch nichts den leuten zehnmal
am tag zu sagen dass die lage ernst ist
das nutzt sich psychologisch irgendwann
ab graf dracula mann und kann mir
vielleicht die beschlossenen maßnahmen
einfach mal umsetzen statt ständig neue
zu verkünden nur in bayern geht jetzt
die inzidenz 100 dann steht die ampel
auf
dunkelrot und irgendwas macht früher zu
oder auf keine ahnung man kann ihm
erfolgen alles immer vorgetragen mit
dieser unerträglichen bajuwarischen
breitbeinig kite man kann jetzt viel
sagen und man hat nie mit allem recht
aber in den grundlegenden einschätzung
der letzten sechs monate haben wir
vonseiten der staatsregierung immer
recht behalten
ich kann ja nichts dafür dass ich
ständig recht habe ausgerechnet söder
sagt jetzt der föderalismus stößt an
seine grenzen genau er ist mehr so viel
realismus
derweil schaffen es die gesundheitsämter
kaum noch den infektionsketten
hinterherzuhecheln wahrscheinlich auch
weil die ernsthaft noch mit faxgeräten
arbeiten ja vom personalmangel mal ganz
zu schweigen
inzwischen helfen zum glück
bundeswehrsoldaten
jetzt wird er hier dringender gebraucht
und recherchiert kontaktpersonen von
corona infizierten hatten sie direkten
kontakt zu ihm sind von
körperflüssigkeiten haben sie den mann
geküsst auch so richtig mit zunge nichts
mit corona zu tun aber es hat ihn halt
interessiert dass eine zweite welle
kommt war doch völlig klar wurde uns
immer gesagt man hatte also monate zeit
diese ämter vernünftig aufzustellen
wir sitzen da schon arbeitslose
reisebüro leute und kein witz rentner
warum ich und sie hatten kontakt zu
ihren kindern haben sie es gut meine
besuche mich ja fast gar nicht mehr
damals vor stalingrad hatten wir auch so
eine art lockdown ich möchte sehr gern
die super illu abonnieren
ich hab da so eine eitrige stelle am fuß
main sid das ist corona
deutsche ringer unser letztes aufgebot
gegen kuchen
ja das werden jetzt wohl noch ein paar
sehr stressige wochen monate aber dann
kommt der impfstoff hoffentlich also in
den glücklichen ländern die reich genug
sind für das vorbestellen das sehr klar
über 40 potenzielle impfstoffe sind
weltweit schon in der klinischen
erprobung
wie sind denn so die chancen dass da am
ende ein deutsches unternehmen die nase
vorn hat mein haus unterstützt die
impfstoffentwicklung seit langem
ach du liebe güte wir sind raus spaß
einige deutsche firmen liegen sogar
richtig gut im rennen heißt es
so und jetzt kommt die sensation freunde
während die egoistischen amerikaner
schon 800 millionen impfdosen natürlich
nur für sich reserviert haben arbeitet
unsere eu ich wiederhole die eu hier mal
regelrecht zusammen ein völlig neues
konzept wir verhandeln zusammen mit den
pharmakonzernen und gehen zusammen
impfdosen shoppen zu den 200 millionen
von johnson johnson noch einmal 200
millionen von bionic sowie 300 millionen
von astrazeneca dazu noch 300 millionen
von sanofi gsk 405 millionen von chur
weg sowie 80 millionen von moderner wie
einer fleischtheke dann nämlich noch 200
millionen von dem sanofi und packen sie
mir noch was jagdwurst dabei es ist halt
am ende wie roulette oder oder wie
hütchenspiel
du weißt ja nicht welcher impfstoff am
ende funktioniert also kaufst du alles
allerdings müssten die verhandlungen der
eu deutlich transparenter sein zum
beispiel enthalten die vorverträge mit
den herstellern eine art haftungs deckel
heißt bei verbraucher klagen wegen
eventueller nebenwirkungen würden die
eu-staaten einen signifikanten teil der
kosten übernehmen
das muss wohl sein bei dem
entwicklungstempo aber dann soll man das
bitte auch komplett offenlegen
sonst ist das wasser auf die mühlen der
verschwörungs heinis so drei
verschiedene impfungen sind wohl in der
verlosung mein favorit ist ganz klar die
italienische firma
sie ist für den eigentlichen impfstoff
verantwortlich und nutzt dafür wären von
gorillas
[Musik]
wir sammeln proben
grundsätzlich sind es stuhlproben von
gorillas natürlich man könnte dem
gorilla wahrscheinlich auch blut
abnehmen aber wer traut sich dass es
klingt unhygienisch ist aber genial
vector impfung nennt sich das viren aus
dem gorilla code werden als
transportmittel für den ungefährlichen
teil das kogit virus benutzt da stecke
ich jetzt alle mein geld rein
vergessen sie gold lachen sie sich
kaputt über ets jetzt stinkreich werden
mit gorilla kacke der stoff aus dem der
impfstoff ist die affen größte
investition seit eigentumswohnungen in
bozen das ist der heiße scheiß jetzt von
moody's mit aaa bewertet und anleger die
langfristig denken kaufen sie sich einen
eigenen gorilla und füttern ihn gut
gorilla kg garantiert besser als neue
curt aktien großartig nie mehr bitcoins
nur noch gorilla co alle hoffen auf den
impfstoff dachte ich aber von wegen
aktuelle umfrage der uni heidelberg nur
noch 55 prozent der deutschen würden
sich gerade gegen korona impfen lassen
könnte eng werden mit der
herdenimmunität gerade mal 55 prozent ja
mal wie ist das denn passiert und wer
schuld das internet die impfgegner das
klären wir jetzt
der folgende teil der sendung wird ihnen
präsentiert von bill gates und wick
pharma
[Musik]
christian ehring wurde von mir
persönlich verdonnert sich eine woche
lang im internet noch mal alle argumente
der impfgegner anzuhören die arme sau
kann man wohl sagen wenn man sieht dass
so geballt reinzieht ich muss schon
sagen das macht was mit ein
vor allem stellt man fest deutsche
impfgegner sind im schnitt eigentlich
gebildete menschen die super stolz sind
auf ihr selbst recherchierte wissen
diese leute erreichen sie nicht mehr
die stadt berlin übt jetzt schon wie man
am prenzlauer berg und in mitte
renitente anti im mars mit hilfe von
indigenen experten unauffällig impfen
könnte läuft ganz gut impfgegner sind
unbelehrbar beim skeptikern gibt es noch
hoffnung mit ihren argumenten muss man
sich zumindest ernsthaft
auseinandersetzen und das machen wir
jetzt mal die wirkung von impfungen
wurde nie in seriösen studien
nachgewiesen
doch impfstoffe enthalten giftiges
aluminium
das ist richtig aluminiumhydroxid
verstärkt die wirkung allerdings in so
winzigen mengen dass man sogar über die
nahrung deutlich mehr zu sich nimmt
meine tiere jedes jahr die impfgegner
sind sauer weil sie das ganze aluminium
für ihre hüte brauchen impfstoffe
verursachen schwere impfschäden im
schnitt 34 impfkomplikationen in
deutschland pro jahr bei über 50
millionen impfungen und nein man kriegt
davon auch keinen autismus außerdem
heilpraktiker die impfschäden
diagnostizieren arbeiten oft nicht
wissenschaftlich im engeren sinne
zuvor war sein strahlendes weiteres
lebendiges kind und nach der impfung ist
es halt immer weiter bergab gegangen
aber ist es sagen wir mal
wissenschaftlich statthaft von einem
einzelfall jetzt hochzurechnen das
impfen absolut recht nein ist unfassbar
meine impfen hat die lebenserwartung der
menschen enorm erhöht die
kindersterblichkeit massiv gesenkt und
das ist eine diabolische verschwörung
sagt sie man kann man irgendetwas von
dem quark ernst nimmt ja vorsicht mit
dieser arroganz vorsicht in dem meer von
irrsinn den ich mir ihretwegen reifen
musste gab es tatsächlich einen mann der
mich zum nachdenken gebracht hat sagt
die im impfstoff den sollen alle
bekommen
das dient der kontrolle kippe da wird
gleichzeitig ein mikrochip mit in den
körper injiziert und über 5 g werden
dann die leute mit hilfe des mikrochips
überwacht moment nicht lachen welche
nicht lachen ich hab mich da direkt mal
eingelesen
da ist durchaus was dran stichwort
elektro sensibilität schon mal gehört
handy strahlung verursacht zeltabbau das
sind quasi hochfrequente
elektromagnetische felder die unser
immunsystem attackieren
das war selber spaß oder ich wünschte
ich wünschte es wäre so aber spüren sie
nicht auch immer dieses locken immer
wenn sie eine sms screen immer dieses
jucken das ist fünf g5 gehe wählen
produzieren das corona virus und tragen
zu seiner verbreitung bei und am ende
geht es natürlich um gedankenkontrolle
das ist ja klar
ja also hören sie bitte auf meine
gedanken zu lesen welche sie lesen
gerade schon wieder meine gedanken
zusammen mit der telekom das sehe ich
doch in ihren dummen grinsen aber ich
weiß auch was sie denken und wieder
einen verloren christian wendler
ja mal gucken ob und wann der impfstoff
kommt bis dahin muss die politik weiter
auf unser aller vernunft hoffen
diese woche haben sie vielleicht gesehen
wurden mehrere weihnachtsmärkte ganz
abgesagt ja nix mehr glühwein also
serpentinen mit nelken europa und wenn
ich das alles richtig verstanden habe
ist sogar weihnachten insgesamt in
gefahr wie der winter wird wie unser
weihnachten wird das entscheidet sich in
diesen kommenden tagen und wochen wollen
wir vielleicht tatsächlich das
weihnachtsfest die weihnachtsferien
massiv riskiert das entscheiden wir alle
durch unser handeln hat sich das mal vor
weihnachten nicht in die kirche nicht zu
den schwiegereltern ich möchte das gar
nicht zu ende denken jetzt heißt es also
aus berlin wenn ihr mich brav seit
nehmen wir euch weihnachten weg aber
machen wir uns nichts vor das wird in
diesem jahr ohnehin kein normales fest
der liebe die weihnachtsgeschichte nach
corona mit aushub speaker friedemann
weise
liebe gemeinde die adventszeit wird in
diesem jahr anders sein
chris rea sinkt im radio bleiben home
for christmas und das unvermeidliche
last christmas könnte die risikogruppe
dieses jahr auch falsch verstehen
wir denken in dieser weihnachtszeit
nicht nur an jesu geburt vor über 2000
jahren sondern auch an den ersten
geburtstag von corona das kleine virus
erblickte im dezember vor einem jahr das
licht der welt viele hätten sich über
einen playstation mehr gefreut vor 2000
jahren ist die kanzlerin noch kaiser
augustus und befahl das an weihnachten
alle zu hause sind ein jeder in seiner
stadt um sich zellen zu lassen
im grunde eine frühe version des robert
koch instituts liebe gemeinde die
parallelen zwischen jesus und virus sind
verblüffend beide kamen durch
unbefleckte empfängnis auf die welt bei
dem einen war der heilige geist im spiel
bei dem anderen eine fledermaus aber
nicht verwechseln den kleinen jesus
legte man in eine krippe das virus
halten geistig arme bis heute für eine
grippe zwei völlig verschiedene sachen
damals dachten die drei könige aus dem
morgenland weiter gold und myrrhe heute
bringen die drei virologen aus dem
abendland nur schlechte laune
jesus und virus beide mögen
menschenmassen was dem einen die
bergpredigt ist dem anderen sein abriss
ihn ist der eine verbreitet seine
botschaft über das wort der andere auch
vor allem bei feuchter aussprache und
genau wie jesus muss auch das virus wohl
damit leben dass da draußen immer noch
ein paar bekloppte einfach nicht dran
glauben
schade und armen und nun liebe gemeinde
singen wir gemeinsam beziehungsweise ihr
sind nur wegen aero sohlen ich singe
jetzt gemeinsam mit 519 ovid navidad
rubina wieder kubina wieder zu bieten
weihnachten wird
dieses jahr hat
[Musik]
eine infektion von mensch und keine
infektion
mit milden verlauf
rubina wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
last ich hab die schnauze voll los lasst
ein abo da